[Music]
we're gonna build our own vibrators
we're gonna become vibrated technician
my dream job
mine too I can barely say the word
vibrator so will you just go back to
calling the marital AIDS the goal of
masturbating or like drive me to get
it's done into a really good job the
worst case scenario is that I build one
I use it and I electrocute myself and
that's how I die my name is T designer
co-founder at crave manufacturer of
luxury sex toys for women I'm an
industrial designer I've been designing
consumer products for almost 15 years
about ten years ago I decided I wanted
to nine sex toys I think doing this
built today will help to pull away some
that shame and stigma around pleasure
people know what goes into their food so
why can't they know what goes into their
vibrator what of that this is a kit that
contains the motors the battery the PCB
and all the other parts that will go
into assembling the final product this
is the best day of my life I know this
is pretty dull we get to pick our own
color we will use a couple of screws
from here with a screwdriver and this
type of adhesive which will help to keep
the screws down so now what you're gonna
do is gonna screw that in tiny screw
down all coming together dip it in there
and then you're gonna put it into each
and one of these holes even this process
is sexual right [ __ ] you're screwing
I feel great this is fun this is a
pressure tester which enables to make
sure that the head is fully waterproof
push that down and give it a couple of
pumps as a needle moving no okay
that means it's fully waterproof that
means water is not going in or else this
is some silicone grease that will go on
the silicone to make sure we get a
better seal for the waterproofing but
just enough to kind of go all the way
around I feel like I'm in some really
[ __ ] up Girl Scouts crafting do I get
a badge after this I generally don't
like filming things this is so different
isn't it if you're better than IKEA
awesome yep
so we'll just sit like that yeah like
you got to put them in the little hole
this is a vise which will assemble the
body together how will I know when to
stop it gets like it gets oh oh so now
here's the moment of truth now that you
assembled your head and the body you
know put them together there you go push
that together oh it's going oh my god I
made a fire oh well done oh you always
feel proud when you make something
yourself but when you make your own
vibrate Oh watch I'm gonna give this to
my girlfriend tonight and be like happy
Anniversary baby it's great for you this
whole process in general was really
really like simple and fun I few weeks
ago couldn't build my clothing rack and
today I built the vibrator I'm glad I
did this because it opened up my
perception I'm definitely more open to
sex in general and just being around sex
toys experience some pleasure in your
life especially pleasure you can give to
yourself I'm all here for it
[Music]
[Music]